uh just amazing i've never seen a
quarterback who can throw
like he can in those weird positions and
just
you go oh that's lucky except he's done
it 199 times in a row and you just go no
he's that damn good it's unreal
and andy reid the head coach of the
chiefs the beneficiary of the presence
of patrick mahomes
for the next 12 years in a chief's
uniform our peter king had a chance to
talk
to andy reid as part of peter's training
camp tour about patrick mahomes here's
some of their discussion
you know mahomes is such an interesting
guy
because he has really become a team
leader you know he's you're
of all things he's your player rep he
you know wants everybody in the locker
room to vote
he wants to lead black lives matter
he wants and yet you know that he's
going to work
as much as he needs to work to be great
at his job and i wonder what
happened this off season with you and
him
tell me what it was like to work with
him sort of virtually
instead of you know uh man to man in the
same room
and and take me into some of the stuff
that you and he
did this off season basically to try to
be better
yeah so i i used to wear them out with
these little three by five cards
you've seen those and um i'd walk down
to the quarterback room and i'd say hey
you think we can get this thing done
right here
and it was kind of a fun thing that we
did so that was you know
there'd be a play on the card there'd be
a play on the card yeah
yeah yeah and so uh we didn't have that
opportunity but we had an opportunity to
do it virtually and we kind of kept that
going and
and we shared it with the rest of the
guys we shared it with all the positions
and
so you would take a three by five card
with a play
well you guys think we can do this yeah
my my guys here
the coaches they put it on the you know
they make it look good
so yeah i give it to them and then they
they draw it up
nice uh so it's a little different but
we we shared with all the guys we
and and the guys got into that and and
so my thing with pat is he
loves he loves ball he's a good guy
i mean he's a good person and and very
competitive
and wants to get better every day i mean
it's that's
that's how he does it and so the the
players know it he's not
um you know you named all of the things
he's involved in but
he's still a guy he's one of the guys
that has a lot of responsibility
and he's able to handle that and and and
be the leader
of the football team and make everybody
around him better
and come to work with a great attitude
you don't get this huge fluctuation
and personality you're going to get the
same guy and
he just wants to go out and dominate
you can see the entire interview between
andy reid and peter king
at youtube.com nbc sports patrol homes
is just the total
package and the icing on top is the deal
that ties him to kansas city for 12
years
he's going to cash every check of that
contract until they give him another one
you never let a guy like patrick holmes
go he comes around
once every 100 years and uh
yeah i don't want to be over the top on
no you're not mike it's it's accurate
it's accurate it is it is we've never
seen anything like it and then the
attitude and the way he is on and off
the field and
everything about it it don't you know it
almost seems too good to be true
it really does he i mean he's about
perfect he really is and
uh it and i love he's not afraid to put
himself out on a pedestal
and you know talk about some subjects
that are not exactly always really
really popular to talk about
but he's willing to be that guy and and
you know be a leader that way and i
i really respect him it seemed too good
to be true
chiefs would have 21 of 22 starters back
as of week one a couple of guys on
offense
opted out lorendu duvernay tardif and
damian williams gone for the year now
bashad breeland
confirmed yesterday he has a four game
suspension he'll serve to start the
season
it's a little confusing there must have
been a substance abuse policy issue
predating the current cba that was in
the pipeline that was not yet resolved
and that is claiming the first 25
percent of the season for him
there was an arrest in april that is
still
lingering marijuana possession driving
with an open container of alcohol there
could be
a separate punishment for breeland at
some point down the line once that is
all processed so we've got to keep an
eye on that
but yeah it's look they still have my
homes and
uh that's really all that matters for
the kansas city chiefs at this point
because as long as they have him they're
going to be contenders and they probably
will be getting their fingers on more
lombardi trophies in the years to come
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports